yeah you're going to welcome to this
video yeah back to back up the Rainmaker
now with black so you're going to do
yeah this line we see 3lu you see that
quite often nowadays it's a not
particularly dangerous but it's also
very solid and it is quite a pirate ship
why this developing here with the with
simple moves ok so just Bishop d7 or
yeah b6 is also a typical way to develop
let's just not be five which looks a
little bit irritating maybe just this
[Music]
huh what about this move a check to you
form hmm I thought III would be a little
bit annoying threatening g5 but maybe he
just goes for each form I had something
very similar once in a classical town
control game and back then I thought
okay this kind of configuration with e3
g3 and so on that cannot be particularly
great and it didn't really turn out to
be a problem for black so okay it's
let's do this then I think he had g4 may
be prepared g 4 9800 Bishop g5 was an
idea so still ok i can go nite edge for
here on or drop back dropping back looks
I don't know looks a little bit strange
so I'm going to do this
g5 Bishop d3 would be a pretty quick way
to enter game can I do something there
with this King position probably not
he's got so many pieces around it would
be a bit surprising if that would be
some technical or sharp and solution him
i would like to play the crew back
sometime between 37 or something I maybe
it look like that that just it's
definitely she was for yeah this move
irritated me but I thought I have a some
kind of discovery probably I don't
yeah some I don't have a good discovery
which is a little bit sad what if I can
I do something that I get five on huh if
I looks a bit off
I don't like this position I don't know
exactly what went wrong here it's a bit
weird
I'm not saying that this is terrible for
me or anything but it feels a bit bit
uncomfortable and it really shouldn't
shouldn't do
okay so the night has absolutely no
squares like none
97 on the other one let's go here
I mean I'm just taking this I'm just
taking their own be 59 takes Bishop
takes this should be a bishop f1 is just
a pawn I don't see that I don't see a
point down and that's that some magic
technique that I don't understand Knight
takes bishop takes it should be a bishop
f1 I'm threatening bishop f1 shakes out
I should just win upon its maybe not
decisive or so it should be a pawn it
takes takes Bishop g7 I don't see
something there either okay he has some
magic moves what's going on here I can
play Queen e7 here also and he's in a
pen he's in the self pin what that would
be one can still just move the night
yeah I'm playing too slowly is what I'm
doing
yeah I cannot to do this
time warning it's not it's not very
comfortable yet this miracle move that I
have thought okay unless he has a
miracle but he had it somehow 987 looks
pretty dreadful can I somehow activate
that bloody piece Bishop a 896 not that
this is fantastic but Bishop c7 what I'm
a what is he doing to me in those two
games that looks really bad or playing
me from nothing positions okay black
resigned pretty awful just awful
[Music]
I'm pretty surprised that this is
actually anything for watch because I
mean it's not he has no retreat squares
but it seems to work just seems to work
it just has this before I just a
clockwork it works and even this this
work I mean I don't necessarily have to
lose 30 it is just extremely difficult
yeah maybe I should give the exchange
yeah that that's certainly an option
what the engine is giving here just just
give the exchange up I mean I'm not
exactly in in celebration mode here but
this is difficult to break down it's
probably a lot better than what I did
still I should never be in trouble from
from here but I'm just playing badly i
think the sisters are lazy move might be
five is coming yeah this is what the end
would suggest and what i wanted to play
where then I thought okay I guess I'm
tactic whatever f94 I should just start
calculating here or get Queen e72 work
of course this is what I wanted to
originally do but not be fine but I have
this one okay yeah because if he takes
actually the night is hanging and yeah
this is equal and this is what it should
be I mean because well why should should
anybody have an advantage here in this
position here then thinks things are
surprisingly awkward already it's
difficult to keep German yet it's good
yeah it's good for him let's see 7 loss
may be better and hear him this is a
difficult position to play his pieces
are just more active if I've looks like
a good idea but Tim and I'm also more
than one minute down
come and hear things are already
completely completely down the down the
drain yeah but it was a nicely nicely
played came here by white after I
allowed this 95 move I should really
prevent that I mean this this said this
felt a little bit wrong to leave it like
here but I've got this with this idea
actually that's a funny idea I saw this
but I didn't see this okay this is
surprisingly critic of the situation I
didn't didn't see this as so dangerous
because I was thinking that he is mostly
i mean he's putting this night at risk
but he has this as i said a phone before
and so on it just works perfectly this
initiative and it didn't feel so
dangerous to me because i felt okay can
advance those pawns but is he really
having a stable peace on d6 it turns out
it was perfectly OK and very good for
what ok thanks for watching